ja viel länger ist beschäftigt mich seit
einigen tagen da bin ich irgendwie rein
geraten in eine szene in die man nicht
so oft in seinem leben gerät und auch
nicht geraten will da können sie noch
einmal sehen oliver pocher kriegt einen
schlag ins gesicht und ich sitze neben
dran eine zweite sitzt christoph daum
und dann saß ich da und wenn ich mir die
szene so angucke dann frage ich mich bis
heute warum klaus bist du eigentlich
nicht dazwischen gesprungen warum bist
du das sitzengeblieben okay ich sage ein
bisschen was und ich kann hinterher auch
analysieren da spätestens war diese sind
sie daheim sitzt der dass der daum und
dahinten der übernächste bin ich also
ein meter fünfzig entfernt mit abstand
aber eher weil eben so zu sagen wir
haben keine massenhafte endlich keiner
hat deine maske an da waren alle
getestet dieses jedenfalls aber was mich
reden was mich wirklich umtreibt ist
dieses blick auf mich selbst warum ich
da nicht eingeschritten bin und das kann
man sich jetzt schönreden und sagen ja
die situation war dann geklärt oder
dafür sind die ordner zuständig und das
stimmt auch alles für den moment danach
aber dieser moment dieser moment wo der
schläger vor oliver pocher steht oliver
pocher ist schutzlos da würde ich heute
sagen verstehe ich mich selber nicht
warum ich da nicht dazwischen gegangen
bin und das obwohl ich oft ja
zivilcourage von anderen verlangen und
das gibt mir irgendwie den gedanken mit
dass wenn eine ungewöhnliche situation
keiner hat s erwartet es ging wahnsinnig
schnell passiert wenn eine
extremsituation passiert dann reagiert
man offensichtlich anders als einem lieb
ist und deshalb ist es mir ein
wirkliches anliegen oliver pocher einmal
zuzurufen olli sorry dass ich dir nicht
geholfen als nächste mal springen würde
alle zur seite das ist eine spannende
frage jetzt die würde ich direkt mal
gerne ein herr palmer spielen stichwort
zivilcourage herr palmer hätten sie denn
eingegriffen und verstehen sie warum
herr strom sich jetzt schlecht für das
er es nicht getan hat
ist weil er das tue ich verstehe dass
man sich danach gefragt hätte ich was
machen können aber wenn ich diese
videoaufnahmen mir zu sehen dann habe
ich den eindruck das kam so hast du
nicht so überraschend dass er quasi die
gabel der vorstellung hätte haben müssen
dagegen was zu tun das war doch gar
nicht möglich da einzukaufen kann man
denn wissen dass dieser typ da daher
kommen zu den einfach um halte sich ich
kann es gar nicht fassen dass so was
passiert also bis zu dem bis zu dem
schlag stimmt dass da kann man wirklich
nichts machen das war vollkommen
überraschend dann ist auch noch finde
ich eine zehntelsekunde konsterniert
sein aber dann gibt es diese merkwürdige
situation nach dem schlag wo ein opfer
das wird oliver pocher nicht gern über
sich hören aber es war in der situation
so ein opfer schutzlos da ist und ein
täter vor ihm steht und da muss man
eigentlich dazwischen gehen übrigens
wichtig nicht meine kritik hat mir
selber ist jetzt nicht dass ich den
hätte schlagen sollen aber schützend
dazwischen gehen das ist doch das was
wir uns eigentlich immer wünschen und
ich frage mich echt warum das ausgesetzt
hat vom ende her betrachtet freue ich
mich dass jetzt nicht was wahnsinnig
schlimmes passiert ist oliver pocher
klagt zwar wohl über ohrenschmerzen
aber man konnte auch in der situation
schon sehen dass er jetzt also keinen
großen schaden davon getragen hat in
sicherheit war dass dieser fed comedy
heißt der wie ich gelernt habe schläger
auch keinen anderen mehr hauen wird also
das war bereinigt aber dieser eine
moment macht mir schon also sehe ich
dauernd vor mir und denkt wahl gehabt
hast du dir an gestartet 100 mal 200 mal
angehalten das gefühl wieder besser ja
es ist der moment nicht
reichte
abgabe mich wirklich interessieren so zu
sagen ob wir von anderen immer was
verlangen sozusagen zivilcourage und
dann kommt man selber in so einem moment
und sieht ein video auf dem man da sitzt
und irgendwie sagt was soll das sage ich
da glaube ich was soll das aber könnte
uns könnte es nicht sein dass die
anstalten gemacht hat ihn weiterzumachen
dann einige schritt doch das würde ich
mir auch das aber es gibt ja den schon
vorher es gibt im moment den schutz
moment ich würde auch sagen wenn wenn
der sozusagen meiner frau eine geknallt
hätte wäre ich wahrscheinlich sofort
aufgestanden die mauer geknallt womit
wir bei will smith wären ja also das
hätte so viel quasi
archaische intuition würde ich mir noch
zu trauen ja da ist auch schluss mit
pazifismus und umso mehr wundere ich
mich an der stelle dass da so gar nichts
war ganz merkwürdig glaubt es war
schockstarre für mich sieht es aus wie
kommt
sie erst mal
ich finde es auch eine mauer
entschuldige ich freue mich dass ich so
deuten aber ich finde es für mich eine
mauer entschuldigt wenn das alle leute
die nicht helfen sagen ja dabei
irgendwie schockstarre da im bus ist
irgendwie eine jacke geklaut worden von
zwei typen da war ich in schockstarre
die frau die da irgendwie blöd angeguckt
und angegriffen wurde von jemand obst da
war ich so in schockstarre also ich das
bewegt mich wirklich also auch in der
hinsicht was man von anderen verlangt
also kann man von anderen verlangen was
man selber nicht irgendeine psychologie
die ja jeder von uns hat jeder reagiert
anders auf so etwas ja ich kann auch
jeder in so einer situation anders waren
sie denn schon mal in so einer situation
nein aber ich würde auch nicht irgendwo
hingehen wie oliver pocher herumsitzt
und geboxt ja oder nein
werden sie das ganze ist eigentlich
völlig wurscht so aber wenn sie mich
schon fragen
es ist eigentlich nichts passiert das
was sie da gesehen passiert in den
berliner verkehrsbetrieben fast täglich
und nur selten kommt das als fünfteilige
meldung im tagesspiegel an die
öffentlichkeit also
das ist halt der flucht der prominenz
ist oliver pocher erwischt hat aber ich
möchte mich so gerne an eure aufregung
beteiligen habe es nicht gelegen hat
dass auch der schläger hat ist auch noch
filmen lassen ja was sonst so misst dann
sehen wir ja das macht
und sozusagen das passiert natürlich
wahrscheinlich auf dem schulhof auch yao
hatte das live gestreamt nein das hat er
nicht gut ist ja dann war sie hat dann
war es ein amateur dann gilt es nicht
ich mag ihr zugang zu wichtigen
jan sie es ja also ich denke sie haben
ja auch ein stück weit selbst zweifel
und fragen sich ja kann man das von
anderen erwarten wenn man das selber
nicht liefert ich denke dass auch
zivilcourage schon ist wenn man
beispielsweise auf der straße sieht wie
einer frau gewalt angetan wird
beispielsweise und man nimmt den hörer
in die hand und ruft die polizei auch
das ist zivilcourage man muss sich nicht
so zu sagen da hinstellen und
zurückschauen ich denke das kann man
nicht von jedem erwarten aber vielleicht
auch ich glaube auch dass ich teile den
eindruck dass es vielleicht wirklich so
ein schockmoment ist ein fachmann ist
nicht in diesem kontext man ist auf
einer veranstaltung
und dann passiert irgendwas womit man
wirklich gar nicht gerechnet hat aber
ich bleibe bei ihrem beispiel
eine frau wird das angetan man
beobachtet es ist es immer noch wirklich
ausreichend dann zum hörer zu greifen
die polizei anzurufen die dann wenn es
schnell geht in drei oder fünf minuten
da ist da kann ja wer weiß was passiert
sein also muss nicht doch auch ein
gestus sein sich selber einzubringen und
vielleicht sogar in gefahr zu begeben um
einem anderen zu helfen herrscht und per
stunden- sie sind wirklich ein idealist
und
das war sie gerade bescheiden sollte
jemand vorbei
es wurde zeit eine einer muss den anfang
nein das war es jetzt beschreiben ist
ungefähr zustand einen normalen
gesellschaft in den 20er 30er jahren
aber inzwischen sind wir gründlich
pazifik ziert worden inzwischen gilt ja
selbstverteidigung sogar als eine
aggressive haltung und was mich im
negativen sinn da wahnsinnig beeindruckt
hat bei dieser lustigen silvester
nachdem köln 20.15 glaube ich ich habe
lange fast alles darüber gelesen wenn
mich einer frage beschäftigt als die
frauen belästigt angeklagt und befindet
wurden die waren da allein unterwegs ja
da waren kein männer dabei keine freunde
keine verwandten keine eltern
geschwister von männern war in der
ganzen berichterstattung bisher nicht
aufgefallen nicht die rede das heißt in
einer gesellschaft die so gründlich
pazifik ziert wurde das selbst in einer
solchen situation die man sich traut
zuzuschlagen als ich das gesehen habe
dachte ich ja ich hätte vielleicht stadt
großes latinum einen box kurs machen
sollen und wenn ich jemals noch die
gelegenheit dazu haben die nicht fürs
boxen ich finde ihre beschreibung
absolut aber finden sie es und dafür
kennt man sie erfinden sie es gut oder
schlecht das ist diese partie
zierung schlecht absolut schlecht
absolut schlecht wir erleben das ist
sozusagen mein putten wir werden
vielleicht später darüber reden hier hat
der aggressor einen bonus weiner handelt
und diejenige dass ich verteidigt hat
einmal los
weil er die eskalation der gewalt weiter
treibt also einem opfer wird geraten
sich unauffällig zu übernehmen und nicht
allzu viel widerstand auszuüben dann ist
es schneller vorbei und das ist ja auch
passiert stellen sich vor pocher hätte
zurückgeschlagen das war dann schon eine
miniserie geworden das wäre dann in
raten bei rtl laufen es würde eine
massenschlägerei gewonnen das wäre eine
massenschlägerei worden und ich liebte
es auch da ehrlich gesagt den gedanken
nicht dem politischen gedanken den sie
äußern dass wir hier quasi in einer
miniatur sehen was in der ukraine
passiert ja mit einem aggressor und ohne
zu sagen dass jemand beispringt es noch
nie auf gefragt man nicht viel phantasie
um die analogie ist es mir noch nie
aufgefallen das ist so ist ich habe das
ja doch nicht ein neues debatten koppel
gefunden das merkt man jetzt schon aber
wir wollen trotzdem auch nochmal so
herbei mal nach tübingen schalten einmal
und die frage stell dich irgendwie sehr
spannend den gedanken den sie
eingeworfen haben das war aber ein fand
ich sehr spannend wenn andere natürlich
auch aber den spannendsten gedanken
gefahr nicht daran wie sehen sie das
denn mit der entmilitarisierung der
gesellschaft und auch mit dem pazifismus
in der gesellschaft was ihr bruder
angesprochen hat und danach mit claus
strunz debattiert hat
ca also ich halte das für eine
errungenschaft wenn die gesellschaft die
gewalt mehr und mehr zurück trägt als
offizier und komplizierte begriff dafür
dass man die dinge nicht mehr mit dem
fast recht regelt sondern sagt das cook
bei uns nicht vor und wenn jemand gewalt
ausübt dann ist es der staat durch seine
polizei sonst aber niemand das halte ich
erstmal eine errungenschaft und findet
es gut dass man nicht aus dem auf der
straße damit rechnen musste sein
irgendwelche leute umhauen und die
anderen dazu kommen und sagen na ja
warum eine straßenschlacht raus ich mich
nicht zurück aber trotzdem haben also
ich an einer stelle punkt es darf nicht
dazu führen dass opferschutz loswerden
da muss ich ihnen leider sagen die
erfahrung habe ich schon öfter gemacht
ich bin leider als oberbürgermeister
immer wieder auch tätlich angegriffen
worden und es ist mir nie jemand zur
seite gesprungen
auf der straße ja
also sie haben nie den schutz erfahren
von anderen unternehmen standen da war
ich immer allein es gab immer leute
dabei stand und erstaunt waren und
geguckt haben aber dass mal einer
eingeschritten wäre zu meinen gunsten es
kam nicht vor
und welche was hinterlässt es bei ihnen
sozusagen öfter ins fitnesscenter gehen
und muskeltraining damit man sich selber
verteidigen kann oder
das ist ja wie sie sprechen das so
gelassen aus aber das ist ja im grunde
schrecklich
dass es wurde nie bedrohlich dass ich
kannte ich mal zusammengeschlagen worden
wäre sondern es war immer nur davor also
in physische bedrohung die stücke waren
auch mal einen crosscheck oder
hinterherlaufen anschläge anderen das
heißt alles geben bis jetzt nicht dazu
gekommen dass ich je ernsthaft verletzt
worden wäre würde ich wahrscheinlich
anders darüber sprechen aber wie gehe
ich damit um also ich sage ihnen ganz
offen ich klar dass aus wenn man diese
gefahr die irgendwie als person der
öffentlichkeit hat latent besteht dass
man da auf offener straße angegriffen
wird wenn man die nicht verdrängen kann
dann kann man eigentlich nicht mehr
demnach gehen und ich will mich davon
aber nicht beirren lassen